now this lesson we're going to be
investigating this last final object
within the topic of parametric's we're
not finished with the topic of
parametric's but this is the last time
I'll tell you about like hey here's a
new object you've never heard of before
a new equation a new formula to learn
that kind of thing okay so this is the
last one because it's sort of the
weirdest and most complicated it's
called the court of contact we've heard
of cause of contact before in circles
right just from the name you can tell me
some things about it what does chord
mean in the context of one of these what
what is a chord
what is it chord okay yes so to be as
specific as possible we'd say it's an
interval like it's go starts got an end
that joins any two points on the
parabola right so you've drawn a
parabola now put your finger somewhere
put your finger somewhere else
beautiful joining those is a chord okay
but this is not just any court it's a
court of of contact what might that mean
think back to circles what a court of
contact like what are these extra words
indicated any thoughts what was a court
of contact for a circle if that's a
court of contact what makes it a court
of contact because right now that's just
the chord it touches a particular object
right what object is it touch if the in
the context that we were talking about
before we would have said like a tangent
right and I think that we this was part
of that big long theorem that had an
abbreviation if you recall now you put
in some extra lines and it will help you
write so in this case here I would say
that the angle between a tangent and the
coil of contact so there's the angle I'm
talking about equals what it's the angle
in the alternate segment that that guy
over there
okay mister there's the wind surfer if
you recall that guy okay so the court of
contact is not just any chord it's a
chord that touches a particular feature
namely a tangent okay now I have not
drawn any tangents on here yet so you're
going to need your rule
and we're gonna draw not just one but
two tangents here's how we going to do
it
pick a point somewhere below or outside
your parabola so not in here don't do it
here find a point somewhere in this
region here don't make it too far away
because otherwise what you're about to
do be kind of hard so I'm gonna pop mine
down here okay this is an external point
it's called an external point cuz it's
not on the parabola it's it's on the
outside okay so we might label it as
such this is an external point and we'll
give it the coordinates X naught Y
naught when we usually pick like an a
random arbitrary point we usually call
x1 y1
but we've already used x1 y1 to indicate
a point that is on the parabola right x1
y1 that's like in Cartesian form so this
is not on the parabola so that's why I'm
labeling it a little bit different okay
grab your ruler now and from your
external point just like with circles
you should be able to draw a pair of
tangents that meet the parabola I'll
show you how to find them if you go from
your external point and you just move
your ruler until it's like BAM there we
go that's a tangent right so there's one
there we go
you can join up your first tangent but
if you keep on rotating your ruler
around right around this way you're
gonna find a second tangent so in my
case it's gonna look something like this
oh yeah so with your ruler just moving
it around so long as it goes through the
external point you should be able to
find this second tangent and you're done
okay
no matter where you've placed your
external point you should be able to
find your pair of tangents and it has
two points of contact there's one over
here and one over here okay so remember
we said a chord is gonna have it's going
to join two points on the parabola well
here are our points okay
so being their external point is X not Y
not let's call these guys x1
y1 and x2
oops that's maybe a comma y2 okay if you
have another color there as a bonus we
can now draw in the court of contact
from x1 y1 to x2 y2 so here's where mine
goes once you've done that go ahead and
label it chord of contact right now
every time we've introduced an object in
power matrix the first or primary
question that we've had is well what is
the equation or what are the coordinates
of that thing right you know about it
directrix like where is that you can
tell me where it is where's the focus
where are what's what's the equation of
the tangent what's the equations are the
normals you can find the equations of
all these things once you're at the
equation you know exactly where it is
well we want to find out where the
equation of the chord of contact is now
I just want you to think for a brief
moment before I start to walk you
through the process if this is all the
information that you know we'll just
stay with the stock standard vanilla
parabola at the moment nothing too
complicated if you start with this
parabola and you've got any point you
like anywhere on the outside how would
you go about finding the equation of
this line what would you do I'm gonna
give you 60 and 90 seconds to actually
fake just don't actually do it but just
map out a strategy what would be the
first thing that you do what kind of
information would you get from this
which is differentiate would you use one
of the forms you already know take some
time to think before I show you how it
can be done one of the ways and then
we'll see if any of you actually can
predict something of the path we're
gonna take okay so I'll give you a
minute to just reflect and think about
it and write something down if you if
you come up with something okay
[Applause]
the line perpendicular to the tangent at
a given point well I mean it could be
conceivably it could be but the one I've
drawn is not okay as I was saying I
don't expect an answer out of you I just
want you to go through the process of
thinking like what could I do here um
it's not obvious is it right like
whatever wait like nothing falls out
naturally it looks like it's actually
gonna be quite a complicated mess okay
cuz when you think about like oh if I've
got this external point over here I
don't know how to find the equations of
tangents from an external point I only
know how to find the equations of
tangents from points on the parabola and
by the way just while we're thinking
about that that has we'd like we have a
formula for this right what is the
equation of a tangent to a parabola a
point on a parabola like this I'll give
you a clue
it starts with an X okay
in this case X x1 equals what very good
times y plus y1 it's actually a really
simple formula right it's like well no
look ma no reference [ __ ] okay you've
already you know gotten a sense of what
it is even if maybe under exam
conditions you're not quite there yet
which is why we give you a reference to
this thing here is the tangent at x1 y1
yeah I know how to find that tangent but
I don't know how to find a tangent from
here so that's a bit awkward right
there's another tangent in here and it
looks very similar to this one it's just
going to have two x'd instead of ones do
you agree so there's the other tangent
and what it's equation will be will look
like this okay so this is so far all I
know and it's not very much because then
I have to find like where did they until
I have to solve that these guys
Dainius li with that to find out where
these points are and then it just looks
like a disaster okay now I'll admit the
method I'm going to show you is
non-obvious it's a little bit like the
way that we came up with this formula in
the first place was not obvious there
was kind of like a trick in there you
know who would have thought to have done
that okay well I'm gonna try and help
you think of that and that's what this
clue is for I'll come back to it in a
minute